hi i'm alana and welcome to my channel
where today i
wanted to talk about something that i
feel like
uh i have to remind myself of and
i feel like i see people just either not
be aware of or forget
a lot where the game's community as a
whole
is concerned this is something that i've
been saying for years
um but i feel like it's very much come
to a head as far as my perception is
concerned
um where the last of us part two being
nominated for
so many game of the year awards is
concerned and also it winning
so many awards at the golden joysticks
um which you may have seen i believe it
was this weekend
uh basically the last part two
took home six trophies including best
storytelling
and ultimate game of the year
i'm not gonna lie this is pretty sweet
said director neil druckmann
and it is worth noting here for people
who aren't aware the golden joysticks
now in the 38th year are mainly voted
for by the public
full list of winners here obviously with
uh the last of us popping up
a bunch of times so the reason that i
wanted to
bring that up i guess first i want to
say this is not a video where i'm going
to be giving you
any of my opinion on the last of us part
2. i am not here to tell you that your
opinion on the last of his part 2 is
wrong
um because you guys already know this
that's not how opinions work you
disagreeing with an award nomination
does not make that
award nomination rigged it doesn't make
it wrong it just
means people think differently to you i
more wanted to talk about
i think this massive misconception that
exists within um
a certain bracket of the games community
that
i i tweeted about today and i do bring
up every now and then on my podcast
which is mostly a culture
thing um that i feel like becomes
especially prevalent
every time it is time for game of the
year awards to take off and honestly my
hardest take is that ultimately we put
way too much on them there are so many
of them
every different outlet has a different
one there isn't an ultimate
game of the year there it doesn't matter
if an outlet doesn't agree with yours um
we definitely put way too much weight on
them from a consumer perspective though
i understand why developers and
publishers care
you know that's that's an aside hot take
what i'm talking about here is is more
of the
community reaction and culture
surrounding game of the year
um that has been very heightened i think
with the controversy surrounding the
last of his part two this year
ultimately if you weren't already aware
um
the games industry is massive if i give
you
this is a games industry.biz article
from september 2020
we just take a quick look at this you've
got activision this year
projecting that they will earn seven
billion dollars
ea at 5.6 billion and take two a 2.9
billion dollars and then these are their
projections so
growth across the board for each one of
these mega
massive publishers if we talk about
video game sales
uh let's go the last of us part two
sales i know it broke records here we go
so this is
not going to be up to date sales but
this article is from june 26th
um and this article is basically saying
that
with so many ads wow okay the loss of
his part two has sold four million
copies breaking
sony's ps4 record the sequel is the
fastest selling ps4 exclusive to date
um again four million copies as of june
21 meaning obviously it has sold a hell
of a lot more than that now
and then i want to do a test before i
get to
what my actual thesis is here that i
think will help illustrate my point
if i go on good old google trends here
and i type in the last of us
i'm gonna do two i guess because that we
can check the last of us part two
we'll go with them with two because
that's what most people are searching
for
and then we're gonna go naughty dog
my my point with this
um that is a tremendous difference uh so
so for anyone who's not aware google
trends can basically tell you
the most uh commonly searched for terms
or how frequently people are searching
for these terms
uh in comparison to other terms my point
with this
is to say most people who play video
games because again there are millions
upon millions upon millions of gamers
may have heard of naughty dog may have
seen the splash screen but that's as far
as it goes they don't talk to their
friends about these studios they don't
know who neil druckmann is they don't
know about
leaks they don't know about any of the
controversies that exist
on the internet that feel like when
you're part of the online
games community feel like the biggest
news in the entire world so let's
have a look if i search for last of us
two
metacritic so metacritic little bump
right there
still pales in comparison to the video
game um
of course there are people who could be
searching for the last of us part two
and finding metacritic on the first page
etc you know this data is not
one-to-one um but there isn't really any
way to prove it so it's just
a visual representation you could pick a
million holes in that i would never use
it in an
actual journalistic piece of any kind it
doesn't work that way
just trying to find a way to illustrate
my point to put a visual to my
point but basically i've seen a lot of
people say um
things along the lines of everyone hates
the last of us part two everyone hates
this game
uh if it wins any awards these awards
are rigged if you look at the user score
on metacritic versus the review score
you can see the public hates this game
the real gamers hate this game
and i don't think that's true at all i
think that majority of the gamers of the
four million people who bought that game
in june alone don't even know what
metacritic is have never looked at
metacritic before in their lives
it is a very specific small group
of people who are part of the video game
internet culture who ever look at
metacritic user scores because to anyone
else
they don't mean a thing they don't
matter at
all i remember this coming up when um
i made a video while i was at ign let's
see if i can find it
okay was this right here i continue to
find it
so sad that any anti-publisher video i
ever made at ign because i did so many
of them would only ever get that many
views i could get so many more in my own
channel
such a bummer but basically this video
is is about
uh calm down alana
is about battlefront 2 being paid to win
this video has 150 000 views
it seemed like at the time on reddit on
twitter
the game was going to fail because
people were so upset about that
multiplayer
being pay to win it seemed like the
biggest news in the world we covered it
uh that was when i was still writing and
hosting the daily fix and we covered it
on the daily fix repeatedly
um it was such huge news and it didn't
impact sales at all
it made no difference most people who
walk in a store and see
star wars and recognize it don't know
what battlefront is don't know about the
history of that franchise
and don't have any knowledge of the
micro controversies surrounding micro
transactions
um because our community is just
so big and so full of people who
casually consume the hobby which
is not a thing that i consider to be a
problem at all so yeah that's ultimately
my point
it's just that things that feel so huge
in the video game community online
in the grand scheme of things are
actually very small and
and we forget that it can look huge and
feel huge because
you know i made a living for nine years
until
now when i switched over to development
talking about video games or playing
video games on the internet obviously
i'm not trying to undersell
or say that it's it's tiny in general
but compared to the amount of people who
play video games they don't know who
made crash bandicoot i promise they
don't know and they don't care
they just pick up a game i also just
always
try to remind people this um this
article
infuriatingly
does not have a date on it which is the
absolute worst
but basically um only seven percent
of americans are using twitter the
twitter population is still 17 million
people
but only seven percent of americans are
using it i bring
that up because i also hear people in
even more broad
conversations say this is what people
are saying
this is what people are doing people are
doing or saying this
no they're not necessarily that is the
seven percent of people that you're
seeing on twitter
you have no idea what everyone else
thinks as a larger group what you're
seeing is twitter rhetoric and twitter
is designed to make people more
aggressive to get more engagement
to have arguments so that you get
feedback twitter is not an accurate
representation
of the world it is not an accurate
representation of politics it is not an
accurate representation of how we feel
about each other
it is not an accurate representation of
of even a global mood it's also made
globalization muddied and that someone
can have a very strong political opinion
and you'll be like well
shut up you gosh dang democrat you but a
lot of people just
read the content on that website
or app or whatever you want to call it
as being local to them
which makes things very confusing i
think it's probably gone up i feel like
this article's out of date and it's very
annoying to me that it doesn't have a
date on it
okay this is an updated one sorry new
york post 22
that's what i thought that i had read um
so i feel like that's probably more up
to date but
i feel like the point absolutely still
remains it also says roughly 10
of those users are responsible for 80 of
tweets meaning just two percent of
americans are contributing to a majority
of the site's dialogue just a thing
worth remembering
the things that you see on the internet
can be blown up out of proportion
so fast and you can feel like you
understand the general consensus but it
is completely false there's one thing
that
i always try to pay attention to when i
read it and i try to
call myself out when i do it
accidentally because it's very easy to
do
is when you hear someone say people are
saying this people on twitter are saying
this
well this is what people are saying how
many people said that
was it two people on a tweet that said
that and then you've represented it
in conversation to other people as
though it is a group and thus they
perceive it just based on the way that
you've retailed that information as
being a larger body of people
i've seen people post screenshots from
facebook for political reasons to be
like look what the
this group of people are saying but then
if you actually go to that facebook
group it's just
one comment just one person said one
thing
no one else was saying that thing but it
is represented as this
big group because we tend to have a
habit of reading
things that we see on the internet as
belonging to a larger body even though
it is still just an individual with an
individual opinion
and they do not necessarily fit into any
kind of box because we don't [ __ ]
know who they are i feel like i could
rant about this forever because i have
so many problems with social media
and what it's doing to us culturally
just a point that i wanted to make to
to tell people to remember not saying
everyone actually loves philosophers
part two that is absolutely not my point
um not saying anyone is wrong if they
don't like it
just trying to remind the people who are
confused
and have the perception that everyone
hates it that you genuinely have
absolutely no idea how majority of those
four million people who played that game
feel that's the reality
alright i hope this was at all
interesting i don't know
i'm alana i'll see you guys next time
bye also because i didn't mention it
because
i don't actually talk about the property
itself and i'm really just talking about
internet culture it didn't
feel like it was necessarily legally
relevant and i don't have to do it as
much as i initially thought that i had
to do it but i'm going to do it anyway
because
ethics i work for sony interactive
entertainment
at santa monica studio okay good day